[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
the title of this episode is the space
cowboy who
find out more about that in a moment let
me first introduce my co-host gary
o'reilly gary former pro always good to
have you great to be here again all
right and you're also a former sports
commentator i'm still commentating still
commenting i'm still out there the
game's gone into extra time i'm still
conversating exactly well you used to
commentate uh soccer and now you come
stateside and you're with us on star
talk we're delighted to have you as a
former pro athlete and of course chuck
nice who's not a former pro anything
this is true okay
long time start start co-host comedian
and actor we add to your resume
i'm often acting like a comedian
[Laughter]
all right gary give me the show overview
and who do you got for us this time you
see neil we all want to go to space um
seems like fun we can get to float
around
up there in microgravity as long as
there's enough money to as long as
enough money to bring me back i'll go
into the idea yeah always get a return
ticket um
but the whole thing is what if you had
to spend weeks months years in space you
know what if it was your job
how do you prepare a human body
to spend an elongated period of time in
microgravity what impact
living
what impact does microgravity have on
the body
how do you adapt to life in space um
and when you come back how does it react
to full gravity so all of the answers to
those questions
are going to help us understand how
better to travel into space and not have
detrimental effects
to our being
um i mean it's going to influence so
much of space travel in the future now
for if we're going to be a space faring
species yeah i mean otherwise we're
trapped here on this little blue marble
and that may not be the best idea as
things go forward so for these answers
to these questions we need some serious
serious expertise we have
later on in the show the space doc dr
shayna gifford her expertise is
rehabilitation i mean particularly for
astronauts
but
what if imagine you had an
nfl athlete
and put that athlete into space it seems
like you know the rarest of beings but
that's exactly what we have as our first
guest
leland melvin is a former nfl wide
receiver with the detroit lions and the
dallas cowboys
he has
been on two space missions on the
shuttle atlantis
i mean he's logged over 500
hours in space he's also an author
chasing space a book a lot of our
listeners may well be very familiar with
being a nasa administrator and
communicator for the office of education
and if you want to talk about what it's
like to prepare
exist
and then rehabilitate from being in
microgravity
neil i couldn't imagine a better guest
neil if you'd like to introduce him i
would be delighted to uh an old friend
leland dude
leland melvin what how are you feeling
man
so good to be here you know sports and
space is something that uh
we all should gravitate towards i mean
we're all
so what you did there we see what you're
doing
gravitate sorry
caught it
nice
[Laughter]
sorry so you're retired nasa astronaut
you're a former nfl wide receiver with
the detroit alliance and the dallas
cowboys
for a minute four minutes okay more than
the rest of us
you only so what you're saying is only
for a minute you were with the cowboys
both with i pulled a hamstring in both
training camp with the cowboys
and the lions and i i thank actually
danny white
for helping me get the space i'll talk
to you about that later okay okay well
the hammy wow okay all right but you
were on the two receivers and hammy's
you know they kind of go you need that
right but i tell you what leland
there'll be a journey to get that far
that will make you uh an elite athlete
by a long stretch yeah you made the team
that's all that counts right right right
there you go and also you were a science
communicator with nasa because after you
did your astronaut thing you headed up
the education office at nasa uh the
office of education i think is the
official title for it but before then
you had two
missions on the space shuttle atlantis
three spacewalks
logged more than 500 hours in space so
you're the man
hey just trying to inspire those that
next generation meal you know that's a
result well well leland you you've
failed
what what
come on
have you have you seen the next
generation man
have you met them man
no no but chuck's got it backwards chuck
the next generation is fine
uh so leland you've been paying too much
attention to the young folk they're fine
it's the old folk that are messing up
the world it's true
yeah that's what i'm saying that's what
i'm saying so let me ask so so i'll
start this off because we have a hundred
thousand questions we want to ask you
yeah um what did you weigh when you were
recruited by the detroit lions or the
cowboys what what did you weigh i was uh
2 220. wow 220. not too bad
for a wide receiver yeah that's right so
that's right that's right and so then
four 540 at 220 pounds i didn't ask all
the rest i didn't ask all that no
dude i don't i don't blame you i don't
blame you that's like somebody's saying
what did you get in chemistry and you're
like oh yeah i got a 98 in chemistry but
i also got a 96 in physics i got an 87
issue yeah i don't blame you man i don't
blame you all right sorry
so
so you were 220 now astronauts at least
from the old days are famously little
all right because you have to fit inside
of a capsule but in the shuttle era it's
basically a living room with a couch
compared to the old days of the capsule
but and i'll tall you also by the way uh
six foot
six foot so you weren't you a little
chunky for that journey wow so
so
wait a minute wait wait wait are you
eating the food that other astronauts
wanted to eat are you taking up seat
space
let me let me just say this
only neil could could term it in those
and phrase it in those terms you are six
feet
220 mostly muscle and he's like it's not
hollywood man aren't you a little chunky
for this role
he is right he is right because when
you're on the flight deck with someone
else sitting beside you i'm a mission
specialist and another one sitting
beside me and the shoulders and the
breath it it pushes into his space
so
maybe not chunky but voluminous maybe
so did you have to lose
bulk
to go on a space mission no no no he
just took up both arm rests
[Laughter]
the person you don't want in the middle
seat of the airplane
both of your armrests
all right i just have to lead off with
that question just oh no okay so here
they come leland so uh
that's my name my nickname is now chunky
okay thank you
thanks bro
i mean how do you as an astronaut
combat effects of microgravity before
you go up into space so what sort of
protocols are you going to go through
what kind of pre-game do you have for
that yeah pre-game yeah i mean
the main thing is you know
cardiovascular shape you want to be you
know you want to run you want to do
cycling different things swimming it was
great but the other thing is really is
the free weights you know and as a
football player
free weights have been always part of my
regimen for you know strength and
endurance and all of that but we find
that if you lift free weights
whether it's on the ground or actually
the equivalent of free weights in space
it keeps your bones
from getting osteoporotic when when you
go to space the morphology of your bone
structure changes
because there is no gravity well we're
we're in free fall around the planet
there was actually gravity nine what
nine tenths of a g in 240 miles up but
your bones start to change and when you
come home if you haven't done resistive
exercise
your your bones may be embriddled you
will come back you'll get stress
fractures and so it's really important
that you precondition
with you know lifting free weights
especially you know squats and deadlifts
to to work the big bubbles in your body
you have fun just to be clear some well
just to be clear because some people
listening to this
maybe from the deep geek spectrum have
never done sports when you say free
weights these aren't weights that cost
no money these are weights
these are the heavy weights
these are weights that live in each hand
and you move them in whatever way you
choose rather than be constrained
individual
press you know those kind of things so
you're not taking those into space
because neil has told us it's ten
thousand dollars a pound to get it
up there so you know no taking wait wait
wait a minute ten thousand dollars a
pound leland you were chunky you were
damn real fat this is what i was talking
about
this was an expensive boy to put up in
space tell me about it they were having
meetings they were having meetings about
you
what can we take
when you get up into the space station
you're there for a certain period of
time your exercise
regime still has to be in place
so a what are you doing
and i can't imagine there's already a
gym waiting for you there so you're
going to have this equipment to set up
exercise and then dismantle so how much
of your whole day does it take to go
from beginning to packing it away in the
box wherever but just to be clear just
to be clear layland was on the space
shuttle which doesn't spend months in
space
so
we might ask
what preparation do you need for just
the days or weeks on a shuttle relative
to the months on a space station so that
that would be two different one taken
question there yeah layla and go for it
so short duration space flight you know
a week or two weeks at a time
we had a cycle ergometer we could set up
this this bicycle
in the mid deck of the space shuttle so
you would go down you would you would
strap in you strap your body in so you
don't start pedaling float away and your
feet are in straps and so you're you're
cycling and then we had these rubber
bands that we would stretch to do
resistive exercise because that's that's
what you need is that resistive exercise
but on the space station when people are
living there for six months or a year
we have a machine called the resistive
exercise device that has these bands
that allow you to do the equivalent of
what we just talked about with the free
weights so you can do bench press dead
lift overhead press curls we have a
cycle ergometer up there and we have a
treadmill and on that treadmill so that
you can get the the cardiovascular shape
you need two hours of exercise a day for
long duration space flight so the
lifting and the running or the cycling
and we had actually sunny williams you
know you know sunny yeah i do know so i
love her yeah it's great williams was
one of my classmates she's a marathoner
she's a just an incredible athlete she
ran the boston marathon in space while
karen nyberg ran the actual boston
marathon and they were comparing times
as they were running incredible
yeah but but one of them didn't have
gravity
don't chuck what he said was but chuck
don't you cheat it are you saying she
shouldn't have yes i am i'm sorry she
cheated
i didn't want to say it but now that's
brought it up
so that's something that's
detailed to sonny okay
just to be clear just to be clear she
has
devices that
weigh her down onto the treadmill that's
the whole thing
it's probably harder up there chuck than
it is on the ground she's got this
this elastic band around her waist
with straps to go down to the base of
the treadmill yeah so she's running
and
trying not to
you know levitate up but those bands are
keeping her down on the treadmill it's
going to affect her
her actual technique so she's going to
have to learn a new technique to run
with all of that equipment attached to
it exactly all right i'll take it back i
take it back so no cheating she has no
cheating she was absolutely she was at a
disadvantage
did you take a pigskin up into the city
and start stopping that thing around the
nf the nfl hall of fame gave me a
football to take the space and we also
took gary
the the nfl super bowl coin for the 2010
super bowl nice so we flipped the coin
in space and and it never died
it's at jupiter now right
everybody's still waiting for the game
to start i know right they're just
sitting around
we did rocks paper scissors to decide
who was gonna get the toss so you you
prepare to go to space
you do your thing while you're up there
and once you return
there's these effects that and
consequences but
how did you
feel about the return and is it the same
for everybody or do we have a personal
variation in the way things present
right interesting so gary as a
professional athlete yourself you really
understand how your body works in 3d
space and you know jumping up to kick a
soccer ball or walking or running or
whatever
and when i came back you know it took me
probably about a week to get back to
some semester of normalcy because your
vestibular system your inner ear in
space
it's the data that it's giving because
if there's a little rocks in your inner
ears or floating
all that data is wrong
so when you start you know moving and
turning and trying to figure out what
orientation you're in
use that's when you sometimes get sick
because your eyes see one thing and your
ears are telling you something else
and your brain is confused and so your
brain shuts all that down
and then just looks at your eyes for
orientation but when you come home it's
trying to re-integrate the the inner ear
data and now there's this conflict and
so if you're walking in a straight line
and this just started to turn you could
just fall over because that data now is
trying your brain is really screwed up
trying to figure it out so every
astronaut will fail a sobriety test come
exactly
i am not dressed i just got back from
spain
yeah and then he'll go yeah right
okay so how do you two things
i mean i've just got off a plane
yesterday and at a transatlantic flight
so i've got some jet lag
do you do you then experience a similar
thing from returning from space
how how do you work with time because
you don't have the same sort of
reference points unless of course
everything's tethered to a certain time
zone back on earth right right so you're
saying we have jet lag you wonder if
there's something called called rocket
and aren't you on the time zone of
houston because they're the ones yapping
at you all the time well we always have
multiple watches on with different time
zones so you might have your home time
zone you have
gmt um you know you have uh also you
have mission control so you have
all the different time zones but gary
when you come home
how do you care what time it is in
greenwich england when you're in space
because
the space station is is kind of slave to
that because you have people all over
the world working that's the agreed upon
i got it there you go plus they have a
marketing deal with the watchmakers
but it is an international space station
and they all listen to the bbc
exactly
all over this
when i got home my uh you know because
you've been floating and doing this
floating
i went to bed and i got up to go use the
bathroom which most people do in the
middle of the night and i started
pushing off on my back like i was just
going to float to the toilet just to be
clear older men get up in the middle of
the night to go to the bathroom
yes
thanks
you confess the state of your prostate
in that in that sentence
yeah yeah well listen if you drink a lot
of water before you go to bed you're
right you go okay okay
hydrating hydration there we go we're
properly hydrated that's all
but your brain your brain is still
thinking that you're in space and you're
trying to navigate now the 1g the one
gravitational pull world and so you
think you can do things that you were
doing in space like if you're eating a
meal you might have a plate you put some
on a plate and then you just let go of
it and turn around
and the plate hits the ground yeah
because in space it just everything just
floats okay what is it harder to do
prepare
for a space mission or recover from a
space mission and you know as as we've
discussed a professional athlete a
former professional athlete like
yourself is so conscious
of their body because they've used it to
to do their business so
i'd be interested to hear how you
feel about either side of a space
mission
okay
again back to as neil said the short
duration space shuttle versus the long
duration iss living
very different you know i basically had
a vestibular
system issue for about a week trying to
you know navigate turning and moving in
in 3d space
and just you know not being
cardiovascularly in shape like i was
before i left because i was running i
was doing all this stuff but people the
long duration they come back and they
have all kinds of things happen like
there's something called the interocular
pressure in your head that pushes on
your eyeballs that's right and causes
you to have to wear glasses if you
haven't had to wear glasses before and
that is not necessarily reversible when
you come home so they're still trying to
do the research to figure that part out
um you know your your muscle atrophy
your bone density those things do
diminish a little bit but if you do the
two hours of
exercise cardio and and the
weightlifting equivalent
you um you know you can you can kind of
mitigate some of those whoa did you say
two hours that's every day yeah every
day they have to work out two hours a
day they have got a space gym
basically every that's every every
astronaut has to do the same thing so
you know imagine you're having to
stagger your rotor right if you've got
jobs and tasks that you need to fulfill
but you still need to fulfill the two
hours per day
it's there's so much more involved
they schedule that into your day though
i mean you have planners on the ground
that put that in for you because that's
that's a counter measure that we use to
stay and stay healthy and and when do
they schedule the couch and potato chip
time
that's on your time
[Laughter]
last question before we let you go can
you imagine a future where we find a
planet that has slightly more gravity
than earth and you bring an entire
athletic team there to work out
under these heavier gravity conditions
and then bring them back to earth and
have them kick ass in whatever sport
they're in that's what this is called
cheating
just just so i haven't had my own damn
rocket okay
is it cheating is it we we take athletes
to altitude training to high altitude
warm weather
and we
extra oxygen oxygenate their blood
and everybody does it so everybody does
it just get your own rocket dude
everyone have that access to it right
right
access to the opportunity right does
everybody a part of that that's that's
what the russians argue all the time
they're like everyone has access to
steroids
all right
leela we're going to let you go uh it's
been a delight to i've seen you in a
long time great to see you and to have
you on the show liam we got to say
goodbye to you but stark talk will
continue uh with dr shayna gifford who's
otherwise known as the space doc
let's find out why when star talk
returns
we're back star talk sports
space cowboy
gary who'd you bring in for the second
segment
well we've spoken to the space cowboy
and that's obviously a reference to
leland melvin's time as a dallas cowboy
couldn't resist the title what up from
from speaking with with leland all the
questions start to tumble as to how you
prepare
how you recover what you do while you're
there but then throw that forward even
further into
with the answers we get to those
questions
how does that enlighten what we do in
terms of space travel in the future how
does it educate and direct us so for
that we need someone in the medical
profession who has an experience
of dealing with these sort of uh cases
the perfect person is dr shayna gifford
now this as we remember at the beginning
of the show self-titled the space dock
the reason being
she was from the
2015-2016 high seas four
one-year mission to virtual mars
so to go through that whole discipline
that whole knowledge set exists in one
person so for me this is our perfect
follow-up guest shane shannon giver
welcome to star talk thank you neil
excellent and i i see on your uh resume
here resident physician
in rehabilitation at university of
washington st louis
that was a long time well that was a
long time ago we're flashing back i
graduated from that program yes wash you
here in beautiful saint louis home of
the arch center of our center of our
country yes
excellent and so tell us about high seas
what was that about
all right the hawaii
space
exploration analog and simulation as
well so it's acronym
see what you did there yeah isn't it
always an acronym though
in space it's always an acronym in fact
maybe my name is an acronym i should
probably check
um so what do you mean a one-year
virtual mission to mars does that make
you a virtual doctor
well if i'm if i'm taking care of you
over the internet it does
[Laughter]
a good one
so yeah no i mean virtual missions i'm a
virtu i'm an analog astronaut i
participated in space simulations my
first was for nasa at johnson space
center locked in a big air hangar in a
spacecraft and they locked they locked
us in they shut the doors and all we saw
on the screens was space for about a
week until they told us to get in our
rocket ship and explore an asteroid and
then they flew us home we had mission
control the whole setup it was very real
and very scary at times and then we did
so well on that that two of us got sent
up to simulated mars for a year
and we spent a year living on the side
of a barren although not totally
unactive volcano the volcano
occasionally woke up and reminded us we
were on a volcano
but
he spent a year
yeah
300.
did i hear you correctly a year neil you
know i did i made you a movie from there
no i know but i still don't believe
still it's still crazy and there's no
there was no like vending machine for
twinkies in it or something oh i didn't
say that
[Laughter]
yeah what else what else would you take
to mars twinkies never spoiled let's see
yeah yeah
an entire hospital full of equipment
nurses phlebotomists yeah uh yeah that
would be great unfortunately i literally
had a doctor bag like the doctors of old
really that's what i had for a whole
year like a little black doctor's bag
like yes like like a norman rockwell
doctor back yeah yeah indeed and it
unbuckles open and opens up yeah it has
a brass latch and everything wow i would
i would think they would at least like
plate it off and gave you one of those
little tricorder readers that they from
star trek oh and they did and it had a
little laser function everything made
great fun sounds but it didn't actually
do anything unfortunately it was very
disappointing
so you made the sound though
let's get this into an interesting
subject because
one question before you go bro
gary i got it because you know i got to
do this
you're the space doc
did you ever even
just messing with somebody turn to
anyone and go
he's dead gym
[Laughter]
or say
i'm a doctor not a
butcher damn it or something like that
yeah you know but when a colleague's
spacesuit almost caught on fire and he
had to come out of the airlock so that
it didn't catch on fire i thought to
myself am i a doctor i'm a doctor not a
fireman right yes right okay you get
your spacesuit can't catch on fire
that's right out but you gotta you gotta
say that right yeah
that sounds like a practical joke that
went wrong
it uh
everything goes wrong
this is why we practice this is why we
do it space simulations because
everything that can go wrong in space
will go wrong fantastically in space you
mentioned
i mean all right we got onto twinkies
and everything else and then you realize
you're not up there with a kit a fully
functional kitchen
but you must be doing something up there
to get some fresh
produce are you growing are you
culturing what's happening in that
environment or is it all like you know
what stick a dollar in the machine and
out comes whatever it is you need and
just to be clear it's not up there it's
in there right where was this
in in our dome
dome on the range dome on the volcano we
did actually have a fully functional
kitchen because it started as a food
study
in fact we had a gourmet kitchen but on
the iss they don't exactly have a
gourmet kitchen and in the experiment at
nasa i we were the rehydrators in chief
we literally had a a bag of warm water
and we injected it into our meals shook
it vigorously
and enjoyed this worked well except for
the cereal
when you rehydrate cereal which had milk
powder on it it does not go well those
cheerios those cheerios do not hold up
i'm just saying but no um we grow to
answer your question gary we grow we
culture we cultivate but in small volume
space is at a premium in space so you
can get some micronutrients and some
macronutrients spaces at a premium in
space spaces at a premium so really we
would we could grow as much as we needed
to live
but we don't have the space and space to
do that
so we were discussing with leland about
you know you your
your bones and the density
is there anything you as a doctor
can do to to mitigate those
circumstances or have we already done it
by adjusting the gravity within the
environment you're in yeah because chuck
would just rather take a pill and go
back to his couch and not have to spend
time we've tried that chuck we've tried
to take a pill and do anything
and i could see that i could see you
doing that just about anything next time
we meet i'm going to give you some pills
and ask you to do some things so
um yeah you know we've tried everything
we have tried pills called
bisphosphonates which we give to people
with osteoporosis on earth who don't
have enough bone
right it turns out that the risks
outweigh the benefits we weren't getting
a lot out of it so we stopped doing that
we do supplement though calcium
and phosphorus and other things you need
just like on earth to build bone so in
my patients who are in wheelchairs who
don't load their skeletons by walking in
space you don't load your skeleton by
walking we heavily supplement vitamin d
calcium there's those things you need to
scaffold and build bone so the
astronauts get get their vitamins and
minerals and then like leland was saying
two hours a day of exercise where we
load people on the t2 treadmill by
putting a waistband on them and
literally bungee cording them to the
treadmill so that they do some advancing
and they do some strikes it's the foot
strikes right it's that it's pounding
right yeah
i read a uh study years ago that talked
about how runners actually have better
bone density because of the pounding
which is also something that wears their
bones so it was this weird kind of you
got to find this equilibrium it's yeah
it's a rejuvenative thing i mean if it
doesn't break your bones and give your
shin splints it'll make you better
that's the point right
yeah or for my boston marathoners if it
doesn't make you pass out after mile 20
right right but i used to take care of
marathoners uh sportsmen sports women
and during kova they stopped running for
a while they told everyone just stay
indoors and immediately all these people
developed knee pain hip pain back pain
and they came into my office and they
said doc i've been running 20 30 40
miles a week for years why am i hurting
now and i said because you stopped right
you stopped and i feel i feel that way
about drinking
you've been ex you've been treating your
existential pain with alcohol but you
haven't you haven't stopped drinking so
how do you know
oh my god that was so well played i'm at
a loss that was so well played and
there's no there's no come back just
shut up now oh
yeah let me let me defer shayna i will
now be
uh goose to your maverick you can be
maverick now i got a big
there was a mission astro access
experiment that you were involved in
um
i mean these
am i right here the para astronauts
correct and then
if you look at that in in a microgravity
were these people actually able to
propel themselves upright rather than
not have to be wheelchair propelled and
how is this developing in terms of
astronauts that's a great question so mr
mission astro access um we put myself
two flight surgeons put and and a whole
team an amazing team put 12 people who i
say are adapted visually some of them
had no sight
auditorially or vestibularly some of
them had no no hearing and then mobility
wise some of them propelled by
wheelchairs on earth which you put them
in space
with their arms with their own arms or
in the case of of of dana boles who's
who works for nasa and was one of our
wonderful ambassadors she was born
without arms or legs so she propels uh
by a via electric wheelchair beautifully
and has worked for nasa for many years
they in in in microgravity or lunar
gravity or martian gravity we had all
kinds of gravity during this mission um
many of them could
could stand could extend
into full extension and the look on
their face when you haven't stood
in 12 years
or 10 years when you haven't extended
without many people helping you or
without having to hold on to a bar when
of your own free will
you just stood it was incredible and one
of our ambassadors who has a very rare
genetic condition
stood on his own for the first time in
his life
in lunar gravity
it was remarkable it was remarkable eric
you are amazing
so
let me ask this follow-up question are
para astronauts
teaching scientists now of maybe how
being adaptive
in a microgravity
will help future space endeavors
i think para astronauts and para
athletes people who are adapted to life
on earth and have to function
differently here all the time
you know you put high functioning people
like leland who are literally rock stars
superstars star athletes you put them in
space and suddenly they're disabled they
have to learn how to function in that
environment you take people on earth who
are who are labeled as disabled but they
function beautifully you put them in a
new environment and they just flip on a
dime they know what it means to adapt
they know what it means to change to
have to do things differently to not be
suited to the environment you're in
are so much better and faster at this
than any of us ever will be
that i think they have a lot to teach us
i really do i can't wait till we get one
of them up there that was that was the
premise of the movie what's the movie
where the blue people on the planet
pandora but the main character
thank you avatar but the main power uh
he was a paraplegic and
because he couldn't use his legs he
immediately acclimated to the avatar he
was he was completely used to just
changing his mental environment right
really how we function in the world is
about our mental model of the world and
what we're supposed to be able to do and
how we function when your mental model
is i'm going to make it happen no matter
what you cannot stop me which is the
mental model of every single adapted
every single disabled person in the
world
then you put them in a new environment
they're just going to adapt
are we looking at this i'll call it the
standard body shape
maybe not being the best solution
in a microgravity environment
it goes to being one of many possible
solutions one of many possible ways to
be not the best way just a way and now
sawyer for example sawyer works for nasa
as well down in florida
at kennedy space center you know he's
been ambulating propelling with the
wheelchair for many years you put sawyer
on the international space station he's
going to move around as well as anyone
else and he's not going to try to use
his feet
it wouldn't occur to him to do that
everything is going to be arm-powered
he's going to be fast much faster than
people who are used to walking are going
to be the second you put sawyer up there
and sawyer we're going to get you up
there my friend you just wait so so it
sounds like it's not only from what we
learned from leland what you do with
your body to get in shape but your mind
as well
the adaptability of your mind
and how it then thinks about your body
seems to be at least half the effort
up there in space
i'd say it's closer to eighty percent
yeah
they're right the other twenty percent
is following the procedure the checklist
that says do this don't do that do this
don't do that and by the way chuck there
is a point in the checklist where you
get to it you're like time to panic oh
exactly
exactly i would take a break and we're
going to come back to that in the third
segment of star talk sports edition
space cowboy and space cowboy doctor
space talk on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about
being a space cowboy and being a space
doc
relevant to that we've got dr shayna
gifford here who shannon your expertise
is rehabilitation is that right that's
correct
so uh we got to hear leland melvin talk
about
i didn't use the word rehabilitate but
readjust to
one g after being in zero g
um and he gave us some details about his
auditory canal and his brain and his so
what role do you play in this or they
just have to shake it off over a week of
earth gravity
can you help this can you
what's your role
in getting astronauts to get back to 1g
so we can shake it off and we call it
re-acclimate kind of like you
reacclimate to coming down from an
altitude or to traveling to another time
zone there's things you can do one of
them is sleep
while they've been on the iss we we give
them we give them i believe
we we give them eight hours a night to
sleep but they usually don't they
usually get closer to six for a lot of
reasons that are complicated so we get
back to earth we say
sleep please sleep and then we say
remember when you put down the water
bottle it won't float you need to put it
down with your hand on a surface and
then they say okay and they drop it we
say that's okay try again
try again and you know they get it after
a few times so all of that clicks into
gear very quickly they stop dropping
things they start remembering that you
can't just you know put stuff down it's
not going to be there when you reach for
it again but then when it comes to the
walking
that takes a while a little while to
come back so which is why every picture
you see of every astronaut they're being
flanked by someone on either side as
they're walking away typically or
they're standing still but when they go
to walk down a straight quarter they'll
often be one person on either side
because they may start to drift
wow and they may start to drift because
the fluid in your inner ear
it's continued to swish around in space
but the sensors that pick up that
swishing have shut themselves down after
the first few days to a week in space
they just said we don't need you and
they literally turn off
in most people
so the ability to sense where am i in
space relative to my body and the walls
and other things in space that's off for
a little while and it takes a little
while to come back and we can do some
vestibular retraining we do that with
them people who've had strokes people
who've had injuries we can do some
vestibular retraining to try and get
that to come back more quickly are you
talking about here that anyone who's had
an extended period of time in
microgravity basically becoming allergic
to gravity
you know it's it's almost like you've
been
redesigned
you were designed to function well in
this gravity well one gene
and your your body now says oh all that
stuff i needed for that i don't need
that anymore your body is amazingly good
at forgetting it's also good at
remembering but it's great at forgetting
it'll forget that dripping faucet it's
called habituation it's going to turn
that off we don't need that
it'll forget those traumatic experiences
maybe we don't need that
it'll forget that i need to use my legs
to walk
you'll forget that you'll even forget
that on earth if you're lying in a
hospital bed for too long which is why
even my patients have had a surgery i
say get up they walk and they say doc i
can't him
you won't be able to if you don't start
now you need to get up i know i'm sorry
and just sit up for me dangle your legs
put your feet so that's it's not just
atrophy muscle atrophy that's actually
something that happens with a
neurological connection yeah it's
neurological wow you remember and you
forget so your muscles and your bones
start atrophying right away
first thing like anyone who's had a long
illness can tell you it only takes days
and then your body starts to forget
it the muscles forget the bones forget
and your actual the actual circuitry
starts to say do i need to be here i'm
not being used i don't know not sure and
so part of rehab is reminding everything
the bones the muscles and the brain this
is how it's supposed to work
now you have three astronauts that
return to full gravity wherever that
might be like i say a moon base mars
back here on earth will they all present
with the same
symptoms or does it vary from individual
to individual
like everything else there'll be uh
there'll be shades of difference
but everyone will still be in the same
color scheme if that makes sense
so you are you're all going to come back
feeling a little blue but it may be
light blue navy blue midnight blue you
know some people are going to come back
and they're just kind of step right back
into it uh mark and scott kelly like to
say that you know after a few days they
were feeling pretty good and then some
people and different things come back
differently but in case no one else is
on a first name basis with him we're
talking about the twins
one state on earth and one went up into
space
and then the one in space got the
overview effect so no but they they were
up for a very long time and became the
sort of the model medical experiment for
the effects of space versus earth living
you know the two of them have
both been up and then one stayed home to
care for his wife uh gabby giffords
after she was was injured
and that's the one who's currently a rep
i believe and then scott was the one who
was up for a year and he was good enough
to call me during my mission
and and wish us luck and he was so kind
but they've both been and you know uh
according to to endurance which i
believe is the title of scott's book you
know he acclimated in many ways very
quickly he was sitting at the table with
his family eating dinner there a few
days after he got back
but then he woke up in the middle of the
night with incredibly swollen legs
because his body his veins forgot how to
pump the fluid back up against gravity
they had just given up doing that for so
long they didn't need to
right right they didn't need to why did
they need to so he woke up with these
very swollen legs that was his shade
other people come back and they have
different shades they stumble more or it
takes them much longer to get back to
running so we put them in special
treadmills that are filled with water
and they literally run in a water
treadmill until they get their groove
back to running on earth in full earth
gravity so everyone is back they're back
in their color they're like i'm feeling
a little blue but maybe it's a different
shade everyone has their thing you get
sort of like pressure sores
from if you've been
in microgravity a long time from just
sitting because you're not used to the
the contact
thankfully when you come back to earth
yeah thankfully skin shearing skill like
the health of the skin and pressure
source pressure source happen when
people don't have the sensation and
don't know to move away from the pain
right yeah so as long as you're as long
as you sense your your nerves are intact
usually you won't get a pressure and you
can move
usually you don't get a pressure sore
what they will get though is the bottoms
of their feet have lost all their
calluses
what the callus their calisthenics go
into space and get a pedicure yeah it's
the best i've the best pedicure i've
ever had it's so soft and smooth
it's so smooth so so they get calluses
on the tops of their feet
oh because they're always hooking them
up at the work station
and the bottoms of their feet literally
shed and it is super gross okay
all of them have pictures of it and it's
gross well that's a bad that's a bad
trade-off they come back to earth and
they have to redevelop their
calisthenics yeah yeah nobody's looking
at the bottom of my feet when i'm
wearing some flip-flops so it's just
like you're looking at the bottom of
your feet that's true very good point
shayna
so
what what you're saying is that the
uh the bottoms of the feet look like
they're molting or something exactly
right yes they are shedding they're
shedding skin it's quite a thing
let's i mean with all of this experience
and knowledge that we've
gained how
how do we need to overcome the
physiological issues to say
take us
from earth to the moon maybe to mars or
further
and not find ourselves having to deal
with all of these problems once you
return to a full gravity
we have it
right well wouldn't it be
solution b to create gravity in space
so artificial and artificial gravity if
you've got a 2001 space odyssey type
solution where part of the station
rotates
that will that will give you some
some relief it will it should give you
100 relief why not
why not so because when you lock
somebody in a box oh that's different
okay
the isolation piece is still there the
radiation piece is still there even if
you've given someone gravity back and
the homicidal computer you know please
don't give them that please skip on the
how let's let's
pass it let's not stop for 200 let's
pass right past hell they will still
have immune system issues
they may still have psychological issues
wow and they still have to worry about
radiation unless we've come up with do
we have a magic wand for that too i
would really you know what's funny it
just dawned on me that what you said
we are seeing the effects of
from just the pandemic and we weren't
even locked in a box we were just locked
in our homes i mean unfortunately with
our families but still
that was well now we know how chuck
feels about his family yeah apparently
apparently
i make no bones about it
honey i love you
i can understand the calcium bone
situation
but how does our immune system begin to
suffer in space because you're in an
environment that is pristine or is it am
i wrong
i would not call the iss pristine i
don't think leland or anyone who's been
up would call our space environments
pristine it's um
it's uh you know it's a it's a vehicle
one yard shy of a football stadium
it's an enormous enormous place that
people have been space station the
station is the station is yeah so 109
meters long
and we've been inhabiting it for 20
years yeah and we've never sent a
full-blown cleaning service ill
so um i wouldn't call it pristine mm-hmm
but i would say and astronauts
exercising two hours a day two hours a
day every day for the last 20. do they
recycle the water from people's sweat
and pee
everything no they just open the window
yeah i i i gotta go with gary you could
just roll down the window
so nasa's nasa's uh uh brian cruzian
who's the the expert in this will tell
you that a couple things happen when
anyone here box do you have a box and
you got to get your elbows down to your
guard up and you get in your stance so
our immune system's like a boxer it's
looking out for the bad guy it's looking
it's ready and then in space
our one immune cell called the cytokine
which is kind of like kind of like a
referee it tells our immune system where
to aim
it gets really confused it's like where
where where am i looking again because
normally that you gotta square off
against the person in front of you but
suddenly yeah and um people sometimes
their immune systems react in strange
ways childhood diseases reactivate
um
they get strange rashes
uh but it again it varies everyone's
different
but um the immediate i don't want to go
into space anymore i'm telling you i
mean seriously it kind of sounds worse
than being at one of those one-hour
motels that she's
what's happening to you with those never
been chuck i don't know what your
situation is
i was very sleepy i needed a nap yeah
for an hour yeah okay you took the pill
didn't you so um what you've just
described shayna sounds horrible so why
would we want to put ourselves through
all of that well this also happens to
people on submarines gary yeah and this
happens to people in aircraft carriers
and in antarctica every single year
and every great mission and everything
to be clear in antarctica there's a
research station
and no one is is frolicking or on the
ice sheets they're coop they're
basically inside with each other you
know
they do they do fall like a little in
the snowmobiles but um you know it's
been it's been there for 50 years and
people spend people over winter every
single year and they're kind of locked
up on the base a little bit
during that time i have to tell you
though you really didn't answer gary's
question he said this sounds awful
why would people want to do this and
then you said well they also want to be
in submarines in antarctica and all
those things off also sounded awful
she was just saying it was not a unique
problem too
the u.s navy is now writing you a love
letter
chuck has always known he was the wrong
stuff right for that
you know what listen neil i i know
you're kind of joking but
i think you i'm going to put that as on
my tombstone
chuck knight is the right stuff for a
nice cushy seat in mission control oh
that's what check right so as i like to
say space needs everybody but it doesn't
need you all in the same place at the
same time
it needs some of you in mission control
that nice cushy seat the warm coffee it
needs some of you building the rocket it
needs some of you launching the rocket
it needs some of you repairing there it
needs some of you in the rocket in space
it needs everybody to be where you need
to be and some people love this i love
this
mark and scott kelly love this leland
loves this and maybe you love your
coffee and your air on chair and mission
control chuck there's a place for us all
in space it's just not maybe in space
let me just say this failure is not an
option
if we cannot travel in space without
this
discomfort these problems are we stuck
on our little blue marble absolutely not
and by the way we're going to get over
that discomfort i think some very rich
and very people very used to comforts
have been in space now
and they've done just fine in fact they
came back crying if i ever call william
shatner
you know he's not
a hard player he's not passing the
pigskin as leland is the man lives a
comfortable life but he came back from
his seven minute exposure to
microgravity in tears
barely able to speak so profoundly moved
and he's not a sentimental man
and so i'm going to say
it's and he's and and he's hardly ever a
man for no words the man can talk he can
talk he really can he's well verbose
kind of like chuck so i would say
it's a place for us all to go for some
period of time maybe just a brief
glimpse or maybe for the rest of our
lives it's what do you need out of it
what's going to be your best trip to
space make that trip
okay space needs me apparently base need
you in whichever role i can find in
whatever capacity and right now for the
low low price of 110 000 dollars
the first airline tickets were that much
first the first civilians who went went
flying after world war ii paid a lot of
money you're right you're right yeah
it was it was kind of a luxury
more than it was a mode of
transportation and t-minus 60 years
later save up a little bit you know on
your summer job and you're off
in fact it's there's a line in a cole
porter song
the one i get no kicks from champagne
one of the lines is uh i i get no kicks
in a plane so so that was a
the plane was a reference point for
people who would take thrill rides in
that song when that song was written
so i'm showing off my broadway knowledge
there there you go
yeah so shayna i think we're gonna have
to call it quits there but no no no
we've got to end on that note where you
should check though there's a little bit
of
uh there's a little bit of
space experience for us all that could
possibly change us for the better
forever
there's something out there get out
there find it
there's something out there for us all
all right
uh gary did you have any last questions
yet to put on no i'm i'm good i mean
i've i'm gonna go away and unpack what
we've we've learned yeah sure and it's
good good it's it's pretty amazing to
understand what
astronauts like leland melvin have gone
through
and then
how scientists and
and physicians like shaina gifford here
are able to assess redirect comfort
rehabilitate
and just allow us to then maybe improve
these situations going forward it's it's
fantastic yeah yeah and i i delighted
learning about the the para astronauts i
didn't even know that was a thing yeah
so that's great
we can learn about that
yeah
mina and all of my para astronauts all
12 missing astro astraxis ambassadors
you guys excellent amazing excellent
excellent
shout out to them all all right this has
been star talk sports edition space
cowboy and space docs i want to thank
leland melvin and shayna gifford for
giving us their time to take us where no
one has gone before
no we're hundreds have gone before
almost 600 have gone before 600
to boldly go where 600 have gone
all right this has been star talk sports
edition neil degrasse tyson here keep
looking up
[Music]